deutschland steckt im ampel corona chaos
wir haben gerade eben schon über die
impfpflicht diskutiert aus meiner sicht
ist sie gescheitert olaf scholz der
bundeskanzler wollte sie haben aber ich
sage ihnen voraus dass morgen keine
mehrheit für einen der anträge da sein
wird und jetzt geht es nur noch um
gesichtswahrung wir sehen dass tricks
angewandt werden im verfahren jetzt
werden kompromisse vorgelegt aus der
impfpflicht 18 und der impfpflicht 50
wird die impfpflicht 60 dabei sind in
dieser altersgruppe mehr als 90 prozent
auch schon geimpft und
ich sage ihnen das ganze führt zu
politikverdrossenheit wir haben bürger
gestern schon geschrieben hört auf mit
diesen partei spielchen und deswegen
können wir als union nur die ampel dazu
auffordern stimmen sie unserem antrag zu
der derzeit unter omikron keine
impfpflicht vorsieht aber die
notwendigen voraussetzungen dafür stellt
das falls die umstände wieder anders
sind dass man durchaus eine pflicht
einführen kann ich möchte es noch mal
unterstreichen weil es wirklich manchmal
kann es von außen ja oft gar nicht so
beurteilen aber es wird ja dann auch
immer versucht so auf uns zuzugehen ja
und er rettet uns doch so nach dem motto
und das finde ich schon spannend wenn
dann immer so die kolleginnen und
kollegen auch sagen wir vergeigen es
jetzt mal um es höflich auszudrücken
denn der amtierenden regierung und noch
nie gab es einen so schlechten start bei
einer bundesregierung wie bei dieser und
jetzt würde union vorgeworfen wenn wir
ihnen nicht den hintern treten bei einer
sache die offensichtlich falsch ist dann
wird uns die schuld in die schuhe
geschoben und das ist mit uns nicht zu
machen weil wir wollen wirklich jetzt
auch aus einer verantwortungsvollen
position heraus das richtige tun und das
machen wir mit unserem antrag gegen
übrigens auch viele in der aktuellen
regierung gut wenden sich aber nicht
trauen dazu zustimmen frau bär die
einigkeit heute die man zwischen ihnen
beiden erlebt cdu und csu die hat man ja
im wahlkampf vermisst also genau das was
gerade passiert ist diese traute bei
sagen sie hätten ja vielleicht auch
gehen können wenn das genauso gut schon
vorher geklappt hätte ich sag mal so wir
hatten heute einige rednerinnen der spd
am pult und dann hat ein kollege den ich
nicht mehr nehmen möchte hat also von
hinten rein gerufen und gegen diese
truppe haben wir verloren das muss man
sich mal vorstellen also ja haben sie
völlig recht nicht immer anders haben
können aber übrigens ich ja
nein es ist es ist natürlich so
gegen diese truppe haben im letzten
bundestagswahlkampf sind wir sehenden
auges in eine niederlage reingelaufen
viele haben im vorfeld auch davor
gewarnt jetzt ist es aber so dass auch
eine andere regierung dran ist und ich
erwarte dann aber auch von so einer
regierung dass sie eine mehrheit in so
einer zentralen frage hat also man kann
ja bei der impfpflicht dafür oder
dagegen sein aber ich erwarte von einer
bundesregierung dass sie eine mehrheit
hat und die hat sie offensichtlich nicht
und versucht jetzt über verfahrens
tricks jetzt irgendwie doch was
hinzukriegen nur damit der liebe
gesundheitsminister und der
bundeskanzler dann ihr gesicht wahren
können beenden wir mal diese diese
therapiesitzungen wirklich etwas
beweisen sondern kommen wieder zum thema
sowie in österreich haben wir die
pflicht eingeführt gegen massive
widerstände ich war auch jemand der man
sich davor gewarnt hat und das war ein
mega desaster mittlerweile ist die
ausgesetzte für drei monate warum weil
sie nicht verfassungskonform ist weil
sich niemand überlebt hat wer
kontrolliert das wie kontrolliert machst
wie schafft man das dass die menschen
nicht aus dem arbeitsprozess rausfallen
und wie können kann man argumentieren
weil es geht ja um die
verhältnismäßigkeit eine impfpflicht bei
ebola werden wir uns alle einigen wird
so sein aber bei etwas harmloser ist
mittlerweile bei unicom wir wie eine
grippe ist die verhältnismäßigkeit nicht
gegeben und im grunde immer wer rettet
uns denn von den us bürger denn vor den
parteien und vor dem 2 zwang der der
ahnungslosen unter der hoffnungslosen
aber diese regierungen vermitteln jahr
europaweit mittlerweile gerade
deutschland und österreich sind eine
große vorbild in ganz europa lacht ja
mittlerweile über german angst german
austrian angst nur wer will wir fürchten
uns zu tode vor allem wir wollen im
vollkasko staat so zu
erschüttern bitte lieber staat beschützt
mich noch vor allem bösen und vergessen
dass eigentlich die stärke unserer
gesellschaft in der freiheit des
einzelnen in der selbstverantwortung
legten noch dazu das muss darf man nicht
vergessen ist ein ungeimpfter gleich
anstecken wie ein gewiefter auch für die
für die risikogruppen dem ries dem
ungeimpften der risikogruppen oder dem
liebsten aus der risikogruppe ist es
völlig egal ob da ein ungeimpfter oder
in dienstlichen ansteckte sein verlauf
ist da völlig gleiche also wird schießen
mit kanonen auf spatzen und das ist
einfach nur abzulehnen weil es ist
mittlerweile nur mehr eine angst
getriebene kampagne gesteuert von einer
kleinen minderheit von zeugen corona
dieses mittlerweile
zur glaubensfrage erklärt haben man
glaubt ja mittlerweile an carola es gibt
den großen corona alter die die spritze
davor aber dass man mit logik und
vernunft und sich die zahlen anschaut
die österreichischen zahlen die zahlen
des ak ii die ansteckung varianten die
die spitals belegungen bespricht sie
nichts mehr dafür und bisschen weniger
hysterie bisschen weniger glauben ein
bisschen mehr aber ein bisschen auch
noch mehr unsere demokratie hoch halten
also so zu tun als ob da zwei drei leute
sich selbst an land haben und gesetze
durchprügeln so ist es weder in
österreich noch in deutschland und die
regierungen die daten wurden ja auch von
bürgerinnen und bürgern gewählt ich sage
in unserem fall in deutschland leider
wir hätten sonst anders gewünscht aber
ich sag trotzdem das ist ja auch eine
mehrheit die da ist und es wusste jeder
im wahlkampf was passieren wird wenn wir
nicht mehr den auftrag zur
regierungsbildung bekommen dass dann
eben auch genauso was entsteht und
deswegen würde ich zumindest an dem
punkt widersprechen dass da ja auch eine
mehrheit sich schon gedanken macht und
so zu tun als ob politikerinnen und
politiker das sind der mehrheit nicht
tun kann ich ihnen nur empfehlen
vielleicht auch zu kandidieren nun mal
von innen drin zwischen ja desto
schwächer eine eine demokratie an einer
gesellschaft ist desto mehr regeln
braucht sie weil normalerweise sollte
man als gesellschaft dem ja auch
freiwillige folgen und ich glaube dass
die union als konservative
freiheitspartei die csu als als
klassische freiheitspartei von franz
josef strauß hier wieder wieder
zurückfinden sollte zum
freiheitsgedanken und sich nicht in
linken kollektivismus um zwangssystem an
verpflichtend machen ähnlich ich glaube
man muss noch mal darauf zurückkommen
warum wurde eigentlich die maßnahmen den
letzten zwei jahren eingeführten warum
wurde überhaupt mal begonnen über eine
empfehlung diskutieren
und das war ja die frage der überlastung
des gesundheitssystems diese
voraussetzung ist jetzt offensichtlich
nicht mehr gegeben also ich habe auch
meine auffassung zur impfpflicht
durchaus geändert ich war eben worden
dagegen ich werde morgen für den antrag
der unionsfraktionen stimmen der unter
omikron keine impfpflicht vorsieht der
aber die voraussetzung schafft das
sollte sich eine schlimmere variante
wieder ergeben die auf einmal wieder zur
gefährdung das gesundheitssystem sorgen
kann dass diese wir haben auch ihre
grund ihre grundannahme haben sie da
nicht aufgegeben also bei delta hätten
sie eine impfpflicht durch gesetz nur
aufgrund jetzt der omicron variante
wollen sie keinen grund die grund
argumentation ist seit zwei jahren wir
wollen im grunde genommen das
gesundheitssystem schützen und das ist
eben nur dann gefährdet wenn da dann
auch relativ viele liegen das ist unter
ungekrönten nicht der fall deswegen sage
ich auch jedem das sollte es mal um zu
einer impfpflicht kommen egal wie die
aussieht wird die vom verfassungsgericht
scheitern
weil eben diese voraussetzung dort nicht
mehr gegeben ist und deswegen finde ich
ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich schwierig
was der gesundheitsminister derzeit
macht der ändert nämlich diese
grundbedingung er sagt nämlich nicht
mehr es geht um den schutz des
gesundheitssystems sondern er sagt jetzt
ja wir dürfen doch nicht sehenden auges
dahin laufen dass pro tag 100 200 leute
sterben aber das kann aus meiner sicht
keine begründung für so einen starken
eingriff seien ich schließe mich
erinnern an aber nur eine kurze frage
ist das interesse warum sie haben ja den
gesundheitsminister gestellt warum haben
sie denn das gesundheitssystem denn
nicht ausgebaut und corona fit gemacht
also wir haben das gemacht werden
beispielsweise betten haben sie werkzeug
geschaffen nämlich 10.000 betten mehr
geschaffen wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
jede zusätzliche pflegekraft die ein
krankenhaus angestellt hat bezahlt
worden ist aber so wie sie haben ja
vorhin schon selbst erwähnt die wachsen
nicht auf den bäumen ich finde wenn ich
mir die performance von herrn lauterbach
anschaue in vier monaten dann hat es der
jens spahn in zwei jahren eigentlich
ganz ordentlich gemacht sie würden jetzt
zurückblicken auf die korona pandemie
sagen jens spahn war ein guter
gesundheitsminister für deutschland in
so einer situation hat es jeder minister
schwer der deinem amt ist aber wenn ich
mir jetzt anschaue dass unter der
harmloseren variante herr lauterbach
nach vier monaten ein buch nach dem
anderen schießt und zu großer
verunsicherung führt dann sage ich das
hat er jetzt sparen in zwei jahren
ordentlich gemacht ja in die sonne tief
steht werfen auch die zwerge lange
schatten